clearly Tucker has way more leverage and
way more options than Don Lemon when the
Don Lemon thing happened and he was
shell-shocked I mean I think it was the
writing was on the wall for Don Lemon
for well over a year now he's been a
dead man walking at CNN ever since Chris
lick the new CEO took over for Jeff
Zucker
um his show which I think believe I
believe was used to be at 8pm 9 p.m
right after Anderson Cooper those guys
right after Cuomo those two had a little
Bromance going on he got demoted to the
morning show which their ratings of our
bottom of the Morning ratings compared
to Fox and Friends and compared to uh
MSN MSNBC Morning Joe but then he was
had a leave of absence so as far as Don
Lemon goes he's either completely naive
or just completely living in a
Fantasyland the fact that he didn't see
the writing on the wall everybody saw
the writing on the wall for you Don
Lemon